YOSHI TAMURA: All right,
welcome to IO257--
Accelerating Your
Compute-Intensive Workload
or Application on
Kubernetes Engine.
My name is Yoshi.
I'm a product manager at
Google, looking into Kubernetes,
mostly working on GPU, TPU,
and also multi-tenancy.
VISHNU KANNAN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Vish.
I've been working at Google
on various things, Borg
and then recently Kubernetes.
For the last year
or year and half,
we've been focusing primarily
on getting Machine Learning up
and going with Kubernetes.
I also like trying to
hopefully extend that
to other more
compute-intensive workloads.
YOSHI TAMURA: So let's
then get started.
We'll cover two hot topics in
the computer industry today.
One is Machine Learning,
and the other is Containers.
Both technologies are two
important, critical pillars
for modern computing.
You may ask, why
Containers for ML?
Are they really a
good combination?
And is it really relevant?
Because we know that the
audience, the people who
use Containers today, are
more on the engineering side
and who do the ML is
more data scientists.
Those profiles are different.
And we think, from our own
experience, the answer is yes.
ML workflows can also
benefit from Containers, just
like any other workloads.
And we're going to dig into
more about the benefits
throughout this session.
For those who know
Containers, Kubernetes
is something that
comes together, right?
But for those who
just heard Containers,
it's not so intuitive.
But no worries.
We're going to show
the value of Kubernetes
and how it works well
with Containers very soon.
Just keep somewhere in
your mind that Kubernetes
will allow you to make your
Machine Learning applications
Cloud native.
So who in the world
actually does that?
Who actually use Containers,
Kubernetes, and Machine
Learning all together?
And actually, it's us at Google.
The keynote, I think,
all the leaders
emphasize on Kubernetes
Machine Learning.
And it is definitely
truth that we actually
use Containers, Kubernetes, and
Machine Learning all together.
And we [INAUDIBLE]
it's called Borg.
And we are basically
bringing that experience
of deploying Machine Learning
applications in Container
through search
orchestration system
to open source to everyone
through the open source
Kubernetes.
And that's a very
exciting thing.
So let me highlight
the values that we
learned throughout this
experience very quickly.
First, Container should help
improve your productivity
by packaging up--
you can package up your
favorite tools and frameworks
into container images.
Then you can share
them across the teams
to standardize the
tools and the frameworks
and all the, perhaps, workflows.
This will basically allow
you to reuse everything
that somebody has
created and then
prevent reinventing
the wheels, which
is great for productivity.
Secondly, Container
will also help
in reproducing reliable results.
This is very important
for data scientists.
Anyone using the same image
with the same configuration
pre-configured and with the
same tools and frameworks
and the same data,
technically, everyone
should be able to reproduce
very reliable results.
Instead of someone did
it in a different way.
And as a result, you have to
figure out why that happened.
It's very time consuming.
But through standardizing,
using the same thing,
it will give you some--
reproducing the
reliable results.
Third one is portability.
You can easily pour your
environment from one
to another with Containers.
We can also take
Containers very quickly
to the Cloud to take advantage
of the unlimited, huge
resources whenever you need.
So now we briefly understand
the value, how Containers
are great for Machine Learning.
Is that it?
Are we good enough?
Let's step back for a moment
about the overall picture.
The reason that we're
investing Machine Learning
could be improving greater
or providing greater user
experience through
Machine Learning
or perhaps increasing
productivity
through the automation that
Machine Learning provides.
So the role here is to--
in this diagram-- is to
really get into production
from research and
training as quickly
as possible to maximize
such investments.
For that, we need to train
their models at a large scale
and then deploy the
trained models continuously
and quick as possible in
production for inference.
This implies that for
your Containers, which
has your Machine
Learning applications,
we need an infrastructure to
actually get to this point.
And that's exactly where
Kubernetes come into play.
So let's take a look into
the values of Kubernetes.
First is scales.
Kubernetes provides very
scalable infrastructure
to process massive, massive
number of workloads.
And also, you can
also run Kubernetes
on a single workstation.
And you can also run it on
thousands of nodes in Cloud
as well.
So it scales very well,
and it provides you
a scalable infrastructure.
Kubernetes would also help you
increase your productivity.
What I mean by that
is it will free you up
from managing your own
workstation, servers, even VMs.
It lets you just simply focus on
your application and services.
All the things that
you have underneath it
is something that you want
to let Kubernetes handle.
And lastly, your Kubernetes
applications are portable.
You could pour your workloads
to literally any Kubernetes
deployment, whether it's
an On-premise, or On-prem,
or in Cloud.
Kubernetes provides an
open and standard API,
and it's portable across
various products and services--
really across vendors.
And that vendor neutrality
is defined open source.
This portability is very,
very important for us--
I mean, not only for us,
but for the community.
So let me quickly
wrap up the values
that we just described,
why Containers
and Kubernetes for Machine
Learning with this diagram.
So basically, let's call this
a Cloud native Machine Learning
stack.
In a nutshell, you just choose
your favorite Machine Learning
framework and tools and
pack it up into Containers
and then run them on
Kubernetes at scale.
It helps you to be productive.
It will help you to
reproduce reliable results.
It will also help you to pour
your application wherever
you like, either it's
an On-prem or in Cloud.
It also scales from a single
workstation in front of you
to thousands and thousands
of nodes in Cloud.
All right, I think I talked
about the concept enough.
And I feel now a little
bit uncomfortable
because my background is
more on the engineering side.
So I want to see
something working.
And just probably get our hands
dirty to see how that really
works.
What I've just talked
is not concept.
Well, I've talked
about a concept.
But what we're going
to talk about here
is new features and
products with demonstration.
So it's not like vaporware
or concept-only thing.
And I really am very excited
because these are really all
available to you as of today.
And you can literally
do everything
with everything Vish is going
to show here from today.
First, we're excited to announce
that Minikube project now
supports GPUs.
Minikube, I guess it
stands for mini Kubernetes.
It's a great tool.
It's a really, really
great tool for anyone
who's new to Kubernetes.
You can run Minikube on
your local workstation
as it's a single no-cluster
inside a virtual machine.
Google contributed GPU
support in Minikube
because it makes the
develop, and deploy and test
workflow super fast.
So we're very, very excited
now that Minikube project
supports on GPU.
So how can we use it?
You first need a workstation.
And you also need
some spare GPUs.
So if your GPU is used
by something else,
you need to spare
the rest of the GPUs
so that we can use
it for Minikube.
And then we attach it
to the virtual machine.
We use virtual machine here.
So it's used KVM.
We need to have that in Install.
Oops, there's a timer thing.
Thank you.
And also we use IOMMU
to pass through the GPUs
to the KVM on Minikube.
Oops.
I think there's an
automated thing going on.
So I wanted to talk to them.
Right.
And that's pretty much it.
And once you have that
prerequisite done,
you can start Minikube by
putting this dash dash GPU
into the Minikube command line.
We're using KVM.
So we put that VM drive there.
But that's pretty much it.
And after that, you
install NVIDIA driver
with these two commands.
And if you go through this
step, your workstation
is running Kubernetes connected
to GPU, and you're ready to go.
So let's really
start running a job.
How you're going to do that is
really, really, really simple.
I'm sorry.
There we go.
It's really simple.
In this example,
all you have to do
is to specify the type of
the resource you want to use
and the amount of the
GPU that you need.
So in this particular
example, we're
requesting two NVIDIA GPUs
from that workstation.
And that's pretty much it.
This is all you have to
do to access to the GPU
to the Minikube, which Minikube
has in your workstation.
So I just went through
the quick example.
But let's run our first
Container with GPUs
on Minikube.
So wanted to have
Vish come on stage.
VISHNU KANNAN: Just
give me a second
as I get logged onto my laptop.
Yeah, and let's
switch the screen.
OK.
So to start off, I
just want to highlight
that there is a very detailed
useful setup and usage
guide for Minikube where you
can go and look up on GitHub.
So you don't have to
memorize or remember
everything we show here, and
you have a really good guide
that you can follow once you
go back to your workstations.
So I hope this is
readable by everyone.
So what I want to show here
is that I have a workstation.
And I have to GPUs attached
to this workstation.
So if I run--
OK, I guess I need
to connect again.
Just give me a second.
This is what happens if you
log out and log back in.
And as I go through my
security, there we go.
And I need to reset the size.
Let me just do this again.
So what I want to
show here is I have
two GPUs on my workstation.
I have one running.
That's driving my display.
And so that Minikube is not
going to use that by default.
And then I have a second
[INAUDIBLE] GPU, which Minikube
will pick up automatically.
So setting up Minikube
is pretty easy.
As Yoshi said,
all you have to do
is literally just
type in this command
that I have free typed here.
So I can just say
Minikube start.
But I'm not going to do that now
here because it's going to take
30 seconds for it to set up.
And I've already
preset it up for you.
So let's go look at the status.
And Minikube says
there's already
a VM running here, right?
So there's Minikube running.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with Minikube,
it's Kubernetes
that's really easy
to run locally or
on your workstation,
whether it's on a Mac or
on Windows or Linux, right?
But in this case, GPUs work
primarily on Linux for now.
So we'll have to stick to a
Linux for running the GPUs.
YOSHI TAMURA: You should,
then, describe your Minikube
environment very quickly then?
VISHNU KANNAN: Yeah, definitely.
So let me show what the
Kubernetes capacity looks like.
For those of you who are
familiar with Kubernetes work
capacity, what we expect to
see here is we expect to see,
as part of capacity,
GPU showing up.
So there's already CPUs I
have allocated for my VM.
And I also allocated some
memory, about 16 gigs.
And I also allocated
a single GPU rate.
I didn't have to
manually allocate.
But then the whole Minikube
workflow automatically
picks it up.
So we have a Minikube
with a GPU attached.
So next off, our
next part of our demo
is to actually show
an ML training job
and show it to be running
on Minikube locally.
And then let's see if we can
pull up TensorFlow and just
show us the jobs progress.
For that, what
I'm am going to do
is I'm going to use
a pre-canned model
because the point of this demo
is not to build cool ML models,
but rather show how
infrastructure just
works seamlessly.
So I'm going to
use a pre-trained
or a pre-built model, which is
ResNet, for those of you who
are familiar with that.
I'm using ResNet-50
specifically in this case.
Google TensorFlow
team has already
optimized that quite a bit.
So I'm going to
reuse the same model.
And I have it packaged as
part of a Container image.
And I have my data set for this
model stored on my workstation.
So I'm going to use an FS to map
the data set into my Minikube
VM, and similarly I cam map and
make code, also, from a host.
So both are possibilities that
you have working iteratively
on your workstation.
So let me go ahead
and get to that.
So I'm going to go in
and launch the job here.
So for those of you
who are curious,
let me show you what
job actually launched.
I'm pulling it up on
GitHub because it's
a little bit easier to read.
So I have a container here that
has TensorFlow under ResNet
repository that I showed--
already pre-packaged
as part of Container.
And I'm running literally
the same instructions
that's mentioned on the
official ResNet model, right?
It's the same set
of instructions,
except that it's
run from a Container
and it's declaratively specified
as a Kubernetes configuration.
In this configuration, you can
take and port it and run it
on any Minikube and you
will get the same results.
And that's what
Yoshi was referring
to when he said portability
and reproducibility.
And I also tweaked
some of the parameters
to make sure that it
runs reasonably locally.
I don't want to wait for 10
days for one [INAUDIBLE] to run.
So I want it to be really fast.
So now that's done,
let's go look at the job,
if it's actually running.
So the job is already running.
Let's look at its logs and
see if it's showing GPUs.
So what we are
expecting to see is
we're expecting TensorFlow
to show that it's using GPU.
So we can see that
here, it's showing
that it's using a GPU device--
Quadro M4000.
That happens to be the free
GPU on the workstation,
and TensorFlow is
automatically picking that up.
And you didn't have
to change much, right?
You didn't really have
to change TensorFlow.
You could take a pre-canned
model and run it on Kubernetes.
And training is
already starting.
And if you were to pull
up TensorBoard for this,
it would look
something like this.
So training is happening
now, and if you
look at the
TensorBoard instance,
this is a pre-trial run
that I did before the demo.
But you've seen that
if we wait for a day,
it'll make some progress off
the board, like two [INAUDIBLE]
and the progress rate is
about two images per second.
So this is not really
for real training,
but this is more for
fine-tuning and getting a model
working so you can
actually do it at scale
on really large machines.
So that's sort of all I had
to say about Minikube, Yoshi.
YOSHI TAMURA: All right.
Thanks, Vish.
VISHNU KANNAN: Want to
switch back to slides.
YOSHI TAMURA: That's good.
All righty.
Thanks, Vish.
So now we have our first
ML application running
on Minikube, and it's great.
And it's using GPU.
Now luckily, we are already
saturating the GPU there
and we saw their
application remodels
are heavier than we thought.
So what should we do?
Should we buy more
workstations or should we
build a data center or at least
plan building a data center?
Probably not.
Let's go to Google
Kubernetes Engine
because it's the
best place to run
Machine Learning in Containers.
That's because GPUs
in Kubernetes Engine
is now generally available
and ready for the enterprise.
GPUs in Kubernetes Engine
allows your Container
to access GPU via
Kubernetes API.
There's no need to manage your
own hardware, like workstation,
servers, or even VMs.
Just consume the GPUs
whenever you need
and as much as you like.
This flexibility is something
that Cloud can provide.
And we're also excited
that our customers
are loving this product.
As the GPU core hours, since
we introduced [INAUDIBLE] back
in 2017, the core hours has
exploded to more than 10x.
And this is very,
very exciting for us,
and whenever we have this
conversation about, and getting
feedback about,
this feature, people
are just loving the
elastic, flexible aspect
of accessing GPUs
through Kubernetes
Engine for their Containers.
We have a wide range
of GPUs in Kubernetes.
All GPU models available
in Compute Engine
can be also used in
Kubernetes Engine.
For example, NVIDIA V100--
this is the high-end
GPU with top performance
for both training and inference.
So if you want to do
training and inference,
this V100 is a perfect choice
because it's good at both.
P100 is a well-balanced GPU--
good for performance and
the cost is a lot lower.
That balance is something
that people like about it.
K80, the last, but
really not the least
because this is, indeed,
the most widely used GPU,
as far as we are aware of.
And it's great for
starters, so if you're
done with a
workstation-- if you're
wondering which GPU to
use, K80 is definitely
a good starting point.
So speaking of reducing cost,
I didn't mention in the slide,
but we also have an interesting
feature called preemptible VMs
or preemptible GPUs,
where you can access
this GPU with a lot lower cost.
The difference is
that your GPU could
be evicted with a
short notice, which
means that if you could
tune your application
to handle checkpoint
frequently or somehow handle
the robustness part,
you can actually
achieve very high performance
with very low cost.
And some people are
really using this widely
for their bash workflows.
If you're running
a bash workflow,
you don't actually use
the GPU all the time.
So you just quickly ramp
up and quickly ramp down.
And preemptible GPUs are really
a perfect solution for that.
Now in addition to these
GPUs that I introduced,
we're very excited to announce
that NVIDIA P4 is also
now available as beta
in Kubernetes Engine.
P4 is a very unique GPU,
which comes with a very
fast inference performance.
We didn't talk about
inference, so we're
going to show that later.
But with a very, very fast
inference performance,
but you can actually save
the costs significantly.
So this GPU is a
very unique one,
if you compare it to the
rest of the GPU models
that we have in our family.
So a great addition.
So let's look into
how you could actually
use GPUs in Kubernetes Engine.
In this example, I'm creating
a node pool with GPUs
and attaching to a cluster.
Node pool is a
very simple concept
that there's virtual
machines inside a pool,
and then we specify a GPU there.
And you can attach it to any
Kubernetes Engine cluster
whenever you like.
We chose this example because it
will give you more flexibility.
If you wanted to attach
to your existing cluster,
it is more flexible.
And if you don't need
it, you can actually
scale down the node
pool to 0 later,
which I will describe later.
In this case, we're creating
two nodes with one NVIDIA--
the top, high-end performance
V100 on each node.
And then attaching to this
pool into an existing cluster.
And that's pretty
much it for the setup.
So now, let's
consume those GPUs.
Again, you might realize
that this example is actually
the same as the previous one
that we used for Minikube,
and you're right.
The same spec-- this one is
requesting two NVIDIA GPUs,
right?
But this time,
instead of requesting
that on a workstation, it's
requesting two NVIDIA GPUs
in the cluster in the Cloud.
So I hope this will tell you
that Kubernetes API and also
applications are
really, really portable.
GPUs in Kubernetes Engines are
already flexible and scalable,
but that's not it.
We also have Cluster
Autoscaler with GPU,
and this is really only
available on Google Kubernetes
Engine.
It would automatically
scale up the cluster
whenever needed and down to hit
the best performance over cost.
The nodes with the GPUs will
be automatically created
when a cluster may
need more capacity.
And I think scaling up
is pretty intuitive,
but because GPUs are much
more expensive, compared
to CPUs, the scaling down aspect
kind of resonates, at least
to me, very well.
So the nodes with GPUs also
get deleted when they're idle,
so you don't necessarily
have to spin up
a node with empty cycles.
It will always be
adjusting to your workload.
So then how can we access--
use this cool feature?
It's very simple and easy.
All you have to do is to
turn on the autoscaler
with several flags, and I'm
using the previous example
here.
So what I did here
is put this enable--
dash, dash, enable
autoscaling, and put--
min is specified.
Going down to scale down
to minimum to 0 node
and scale up to maximum 5 nodes.
So if I need more capacity,
it will go up to 5 nodes.
If I'm idle, it
will go down to 0.
And this is exactly
why we wanted
to introduce this node
pool, because if you just
specify this particular
group to use GPU
and if you don't have any
workload that requires a GPU,
it can go down to 0.
And once you have it, it will
scale up back to 5 again.
Yeah, and the other part
is exactly the same.
We have two nodes in a node
pool and each node has one V100.
OK, so let's look into
the demonstration again.
So this time, we're going to
go through the demonstration
of GPUs in Kubernetes
Engine, and this time, we're
going to do the training
to show the power of that.
Right back to you, Vish.
VISHNU KANNAN: Yeah,
thank you, Yoshi.
So I want to show
that it's actually
really straightforward to do
what Yoshi said through the UI.
You can do this through
the command line, too.
So I won't take too
much time, but I just
want to highlight the fact that
you can create a cluster pretty
quickly and you can either
attach GPUs to your cluster
directly, like your
default node pool,
or you can create a
cluster without GPUs
and then add more node pools,
which are showing just a bit.
So I have a pre-created
cluster here
and I can go and edit
this pre-created cluster,
and I can add node pools.
And it's not just this.
There will be another
talk later today--
or is it today?
YOSHI TAMURA: I think
I have that one in--
VISHNU KANNAN: OK, awesome.
So Yoshi will talk about
that in just a bit.
But there, GKE
would automatically
create node pools for you.
So you don't even have to go
manually create GPU node pools.
So for the purpose
of this demo, I
have pre-created a
GKE cluster and I have
various kinds of node pools.
The default one is
the one that you
get when you create
the cluster, and then I
have a GPU pool where each
node has one GPU attached.
So I have 10 nodes
and I have 10 GPUs.
And autoscaling is
turned on, where
I can scale from 10 to 100.
And I have another
node pool where
each node has 8 [INAUDIBLE]
that's attached to it,
and it can scale
from 10 to 100 again.
Right?
So I have this dynamic pool.
It can scale back to 0 if I
want to, but for the demo,
I've set it up at 10.
So now that the
cluster is there,
let's do something
interesting with it.
I'm going to do
something, and then I'll
come back and explain
what I just did.
So just bear with
me for a moment,
and then I'll explain
what I exactly did.
So I'm launching
a few jobs here.
Just know that I'm launching
lots of jobs, and each of them
are taking some amount of GPUs,
and I explain what is going on.
So for the purpose of the
demo, a typical lifecycle
for an ML model is you create
some very basic structure
for your model,
and then you want
to explore your hyper
parameters, right?
You want to see what
set of hyper parameters
are going to best suit my
current data or the model
structure that I've
come up with, right?
So to illustrate that, I've
chosen three hyper parameters
here for ResNet--
the same model.
I've not changed the model
from the Minikube environment
to the GKE environment.
I've chosen my illustrative
hyper parameters
to be the base
starting learning rate,
the bat sizes for the GPU,
and the new [INAUDIBLE] depth
choices.
So I have all the
way from 34 to 152.
So what happened
behind the scenes
is I used a very
simple bash script.
You could do something
much more interesting.
And the bash script essentially
went through this whole grid
search across all these
different hyper parameters,
and it created a
Kubernetes job where
it's almost running the same
command that I ran locally,
right?
Except that I'm updating
more hyper parameters
than what I did locally.
So it's the same code that
I'm running in the Cloud.
YOSHI TAMURA: Can you show the
parameter part a little bit
more, so that people--
VISHNU KANNAN: Yeah, definitely.
So the parameters
are learning rate--
the initial learning
rate, the bat sizes.
That is how many data sets
do you train on in any given
moment on a GPU.
And then you have
depth choices--
just the slice of
the new [INAUDIBLE]
YOSHI TAMURA: And I
guess that you already
started your ML training
job with the first command
that you ran, right?
VISHNU KANNAN: Yeah.
And the other thing
that I want to highlight
is each job here is-- each
part here is using eight GPUs,
right?
So you're getting a DGX-1
box in the Cloud on demand
and you get it when you need
it, and you can get rid of it
when you don't need it.
So it's really
high-performance compute
available to you on demand.
And let me highlight
what happened as part
of submitting the job, right?
So I have the GKE
workloads view here.
What we see is we see
a whole bunch of jobs.
Like I showed earlier, I only
have 10 nodes in my node pool
that has eight GPUs.
So 10 jobs are already
running, right,
because the nodes
are already there.
The rest of them are in
the unscalable state,
and if you go look at the
cluster itself, right,
and if I just
refresh this page--
if I look at the cluster,
what we expect to see
is we expect to see more nodes
being added automatically
to that node pool.
And once this loads, what you'll
see is there's no 32 nodes,
right, because I started 32
pods and there were 10 nodes
originally.
And then now there's 22 more
nodes automatically added
to my node pool.
And then in just a bit, we would
see that these pods are also
going to get scheduled.
But what I've done for this
demo is not wait for these jobs
to actually start
running, and then
show that they're using GPUs
and so on, because that's
going to take quite a while.
And training is also going to
take many, many days for it
to complete, even
with eight GPUs.
So what I've done is I have free
trained for a few [INAUDIBLE]
and I have TensorBoard
loaded up here.
I have some pre-trained data and
I'm loading TensorBoard here.
So what I want to highlight
is that with the TensorFlow
and with the
Kubernetes ecosystem,
you can do really large scale
batch, hyper parameter sweeps.
And you can observe all your
different hyper parameters here
through TensorBoard.
And you get this really nice
interconnected ecosystem
that makes your data centers
really, really productive.
That's the key point that we
want to drive through this.
YOSHI TAMURA: Do you
want to go back to the UI
to make sure that your
pod is also consuming?
VISHNU KANNAN: Oh yeah.
Definitely.
So if we drill into
one of the jobs
here, what we see is
the job is a construct.
It's a batch construct.
Make sure that one part or
x number of parts complete,
based on how you configure it.
So now, if we go in
here, what you see here
is that you start
seeing GPU metrics.
You start seeing GPU
memory and GPU recycled.
These metrics show up only
if your pod is actually
consuming GPUs.
And you see some
actual data here.
I don't know if it's
actually visible,
but the pod is just starting
up, and it's starting
to actively use the GPUs.
And so we can see
those metrics there.
And if we go into the logs,
it'll probably show the same
thing that I show locally,
except that it'll show that
they're--
YOSHI TAMURA: I think people
might want to see a little bit.
Let's try doing that.
VISHNU KANNAN: Let's try that.
Let's wait for the logs to load.
OK, let's see if--
I'm having some--
YOSHI TAMURA:
[INAUDIBLE] that one.
VISHNU KANNAN: Yeah.
Have to go to the
beginning of the training
run to look at the
initial log line.
YOSHI TAMURA: OK.
Then you can just keep going.
You'll find it.
VISHNU KANNAN: Yeah.
YOSHI TAMURA: All right.
VISHNU KANNAN: I'll
probably pull it up
when we do the next demo.
YOSHI TAMURA: Sounds good.
Now switch them
back to the deck.
Yep.
OK.
So that's a quick demonstration
of Vish running training
on top of Google Kubernetes
Engine using GPUs.
And literally, he was typing
the command in front of me,
so the training job
kicked off very quickly
and, all of a sudden,
the autoscaler kicked in.
It added the nodes
that were missing,
and then the job
started running as you
kind of just-- so that elastic
part is really amazing.
Now training is just
something in the middle.
It's just only one
piece, and the next step
is that course of putting
that in production
and do I run inference?
So in the next
demonstration, we want
to show the exact
same infrastructure
in Kubernetes Engine can be used
for inference and prediction
in production.
So Vish, you want to--
VISHNU KANNAN: Yeah,
just a second, sure.
Do you want to switch?
YOSHI TAMURA: Yeah,
we can switch it up.
Sure.
VISHNU KANNAN: Thank you.
YOSHI TAMURA: Go.
It's all yours.
VISHNU KANNAN: OK.
So again, I'm going
to do something,
and then I'm going to
explain what I just did.
OK.
That's done.
So let's go back here.
What I have here in my UI is
I have a serving deployment.
For anyone who's
familiar with Kubernetes,
a deployment is like
the very basic construct
for running web services
or any sort of web app.
So the deployment
gives you abilities
to do [? Bluebeam ?] roll outs.
And you can do AB
testing and so on.
So there's lots of parameters to
do gradual dole outs and so on.
And there's a huge
ecosystem around it.
So what I want to
illustrate here
is that you can use
the same construct
and do ML inference
in production.
So what I have running here
is a Kubernetes deployment
that is serving
TensorFlow or that's
using TensorFlow serving.
And it's serving
an inception model.
I'll show you that model here.
So I have--
I don't know if
it's legible enough,
but I have the pre-canned
inception model,
and I'm serving that.
There's nothing really
fancy going on here.
The facts that I
want to highlight
are the fact that you can use
pre-built TensorFlow images.
All you have to do
is bring your model.
You don't have to
change anything else.
You can take, for example,
my example deployment
that I have here, which
is taken on GitHub.
And you can change the model
and you can get going, right?
And I also want to highlight
one more fact, not just this.
What I also did in
the background, which
I said I'll explain in a
bit, is I started some load.
It's not interesting if I'm
just running inference, right?
I have to do something
with it, and I
want to simulate
real world scenario.
And what I did is I started
clients in the background,
and what the
clients are doing is
they are sending prediction
requests to this TensorFlow
deployment that I
have running here.
YOSHI TAMURA: So
what would you expect
when your system gets loaded
with your load generator?
VISHNU KANNAN: Yeah.
What I would expect is my load
generator to go ahead and--
what I would ideally
expect my system to do
is I would expect the system to
automatically scale up and then
meet my load, right?
YOSHI TAMURA: Right.
VISHNU KANNAN: And so I want
to see if that happens here.
YOSHI TAMURA: Got it.
VISHNU KANNAN: OK, that's
actually happening here.
So what's happening is we
saw a single part here,
and Kubernetes is automatically
adding more and more pods,
based on the demand.
So what we see here is the
demand was nonexistent,
and then I started the load.
Then we see that the
duty cycle of the GPUs
are actually going up.
And I'm using Kubernetes
native autoscaling perimeters.
I've already set up autoscaling
for this TensorFlow deployment
here, and you can reuse
that, too, if you want to.
And I've set it up such that
whenever my duty cycle crosses
the threshold, add more pods.
And that's exactly what
we see happening here
as more pods are getting added.
YOSHI TAMURA: Got it.
So do I need to build a
container to serve my model?
Maybe you already
touched this, but do I
need to build a container, too?
VISHNU KANNAN: No, you
don't really have to.
So in fact, I can
show that here.
So I'm going to go
ahead and change this.
I'm going to change the
model that I'm serving.
That's all I did.
I went and--
I did this live through Edit.
You could do this
through GitHub or you
could have your own way
of managing conflicts.
But once you do that,
what's going to happen
is Kubernetes will do
a rolling deployment.
So we see that version
three is being created here.
And there are also health checks
embedded into the Tensorflow
serving container.
So the old pods don't get
removed until the new pods are
serving--
ready to serve logically.
And that's a key point because
you can do simple rolling
updates, but doing
rolling updates
that are safe that doesn't
drop traffic is not that easy.
YOSHI TAMURA: Maybe we want
to stick to this screen.
And in fact, I think when
people ask us about, yeah,
you're doing GPU.
You're doing a lot
of things here.
What is actually the value
that we're providing?
This screen,
indeed, because even
if it's actually ML
application or not,
it's another application.
And if you're bringing
those into production,
you definitely do want to have
your existing version running,
and then keep updating
behind the scene.
And that's where Kubernetes
is really good at--
and with this GPU integration,
it's all coming together.
So I think this
kind of shows you
how Kubernetes and
Kubernetes Engine
helps you to bring
your ML application
from training to production
in a very light way.
We didn't even cover the
hot, CICD tool chain.
He just edited online.
I'm sure that that's not
the best way, apparently.
So we should definitely
include some sort
of a version controlling
assistant into the workflow.
But I want to say that that's
the kind of [INAUDIBLE] that we
do have on Kubernetes
Engines with GPUs.
So I introduced that
GPUs and Kubernetes
are ready for Enterprise.
And if I just say so, it's
like, yeah, you're saying that.
But we would like to share
some voices from our users.
Ocado, the world's largest
online only grocery retailer,
has been using our GPUs
in Kubernetes Engine.
They said, GPUs in
Kubernetes Engines
are powerful, cost
effective, and
flexible for their
enterprise-grade machine
learning.
We're very excited about their
customers loving our product.
So GPUs and Kubernetes Engines
are perfect for your ML
application, and we
hopefully highlighted
the key parts of that.
However, machine learning, as we
also saw from today's keynote--
it is evolving
every day, really.
And the challenge there is
this increased complexity.
And as a result,
the compute needs.
What if you need more
power in the future?
We at Google hit that
problem five years ago.
If people use voice search
with speed recognition
for just three minutes a day,
it's like five years ago--
a long time.
So I'm pretty sure, with all the
cool gadgets like Google Home
and Assistant, I think this
number is too pessimistic
nowadays.
But they said we would need to
double our data center-- double
our data center, meaning
Google data centers--
they had a ton of data centers.
But they said, we've got to
double to meet the computation
demands.
This really, really big moment.
And this is exactly why
we build Tensor processing
unit or short--
TPU.
Today, we're very
excited to announce
that this Cloud
TPU in Kubernetes
is now publicly
available in beta.
You can now use
hardware accelerator
that Google designed
just for machine
learning in Kubernetes Engine.
Like we have been
consistent, you
can access this Cloud
TPU via Kubernetes API,
like many other resources.
You don't need to manage
the cloud TPU by yourself.
Kubernetes engine will take
care of the lifecycle for you.
It would also automatically
scale the number of cloud TPUs
whenever you need
and as much as you
like, as far as
you have the quota.
The performance of Cloud
TPU is just unbelievable.
On a single Cloud TPU
device with eight TPU cores,
you can train the
ResNet-50 that Vish
has been showing with more
than 3,000 images per second.
And it finishes in
about nine hours.
Not only that-- with
this half-size TPU pod,
you can train with more than
77,000 images per second.
Honestly, I'm not
a person who runs
Machine Learning all the time
or models also all the time.
So this number is kind
of too large, really.
Too hard to kind of feel
what this really means.
So just telling you that,
OK, I mentioned nine hours
with that one Cloud TPU device.
This gigantic thing will get
the job done in 30 minutes,
and I think that's
much more tangible.
So with the time that you
reduce, you can take a break
and go home early or,
more seriously, I think,
you can spend more time
on interesting stuff.
You can make this cycle
faster and faster.
So this performance
is just mind blowing.
And I think you kind of imagine
access into this Cloud TPU
in Kubernetes Engine is
very straightforward.
When creating a cluster, all you
have to do is to specify in it
dash, dash, enable TPU.
We recently introduced
this feature from 110,
so we just wanted to specify
or convey that clearly.
But eventually, when the
Google Kubernetes always
comes with larger than 110, you
don't need this flag anymore.
And we're using IP Alias
in the behind the scenes,
so we're putting dash, dash,
enable IP Alias to enable it.
But that's pretty
much it for the setup.
So now, let's consume the
Cloud TPUs for our containers.
This time, we cannot use the
same example that I've been
using here and there
because instead of GPUs,
we're requesting Cloud TPUs.
So we have to change that.
But in this case, we're
requesting eight cloud TPU V2
cores, which is
actually one cloud TPU
device from our quota.
And that's the change you have
to make for your prospect.
All right.
Then let's see how it's working,
and Vish, come on again.
So how can I use a Cloud
TPU from Kubernetes Engine?
VISHNU KANNAN: It's actually
very straightforward.
So again, I'm going
to bore everyone
with the same model
and the same prospect.
There's nothing really fancy
going on this time, either.
So I have the same model
code that I showed earlier,
and we are running a slightly
simpler set of parameters
here because the model is
already setup, by default,
to run on TPUs because
I used a model that
was already optimized for TPUs.
And that's the thing that I
really like the most with TPUs,
is that you get
these off the shelf
models that are
already optimized,
where if your business
case is just to apply ML
to your existing
data, where you only
make some tweaks to
your existing models,
it's really straightforward.
You don't have to fiddle
with anything else,
and you can just get going.
And if you want
to run it at scale
or if you want to
run it periodically--
if you want any sort
of automation on that,
GKE makes it really,
really simple.
So as Yoshi said, I requested
a single TPU donut here.
I also specified
TensorFlow version 1.9,
and this is something
you can do where
you can choose specific versions
of TensorFlow so that it works.
What I've done in the
background, just to save time,
is I already went ahead and
started this job that I just
showed.
And I want to pull up the
GKE workloads UI again.
So what we see here
is the ResNet job.
It's aptly named ResNet
TPU, and there's a part
that belongs to this job.
And if you go and look at
the jobs requirements--
let me pull this up--
you'll see that it's asking
for a single TPU donut.
And training has
already started,
so you can probably look at
its logs and see that it's--
so see here that training
is already going on.
It's processing some number
of samples per second.
I also want to pull
up TensorBoard.
So I can pull up TensorBoard for
this exact training instance,
when all I've done
is I've pulled up
TensorBoard for an instance that
has already been pre-trained.
And what we see here is we see
that with the default hyper
parameters that have
been set up for ResNet,
you are able to process
about-- like Yoshi said,
about 3,350 or 3,400 images
per second.
And the other cool part that
I really like about TPUs
is that if you want to
scale beyond a single donut
and if you want to
get to larger slices,
you just increase the bat size.
I'm not sure for what all models
it works, but for the ones
that it works, it's a really
easy to use user interface.
That's all I had
about TPUs, Yoshi.
YOSHI TAMURA: Thank
you very much.
That's really, really
impressive and powerful.
All righty.
So I think it's time to
wrap up our long journey.
We introduced a number
of projects and products,
but all of these are
something that you
could start using today.
There's no whitelist.
There's no need to contact
me to-- can I use it?
Everything is all
available to you.
And we hope this talk will be
also online very soon so that--
we cover a lot so you can go
through Vish's demonstration
and really, really get your
hands dirty by yourself.
So just to kind of recap,
we introduced GPU support
in Minikube, which is
great for starters.
We talk about GPUs
in Kubernetes,
which is generally available
with a wide range of GPUs
available and with
the autoscaler.
And lastly, we
announced the Cloud TPU
in Kubernetes Engines.
But besides all those products
and features, what I really
wanted to convey today is
that Containers are really
great for Machine Learning.
And I could confidently
say that from my experience
inside of Google and talking to
Vish and all the great Googlers
inside.
And Kubernetes is indeed great
for search containers, as well.
So going back to
this stack again,
but choose your favorite ML,
Machine Learning, framework
and tools.
Pack it up into Containers.
Run on Kubernetes at scale.
That's what I really
wanted to talk about today.
So thank you for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]